I've never been able to recreate my
experience the first time I went to the
kek observatory um but it was we just
caught lightning in a bottle and I
remember when we were driving up there
we we had been staying on on the big
island and we we stayed on the big
island specifically because I wanted to
go to the observatory I was like I I
just want to see it I keep hearing that
it's insane and as we were driving up
the mountain it was cloudy I was like oh
this sucks we got a cloudy day oh well
you know we'll go up there anyway we'll
see what it's like and look at their
telescopes and all that chall but then
you drove through the clouds so it was
so high up there that you passed through
the clouds and then it was just crystal
clear and I swear it changed my life
like just looking at it that way I I
don't think I know everyone knows that
we're in space but you don't see it that
way all the time because I just don't
think it's possible unless you live in
some very rural area well you mentioned
this you said like it's a tragedy that
we suffer from light pollution so much
so you said that we don't even know what
we don't see yeah we don't we have no
understanding of what's above us and
that the Ancients used to see every
single day Abol that's what they saw
every night so much so that this is a
beautiful picture that jam is showing
this is the alma this is stands for
atakama which is the desert that we're
in it's the driest desert on Earth it's
the highest desert on Earth because you
know 5,000 met 17,000 ft in the Andes
Mountains um and this picture is showing
the this band that's arcing overhead
that's the Milky Way galaxy I'm a
professional astronomer when I go down
there I can't recognize the
constellations that I know and I've
known since I was 12 years old because
there's no Contra like every Star just
is like blowing you away and it's just
magnified so much by the clarity and the
distance and the remove from light
pollution it is a toxic you know it's it
is preventing our children from really
understanding what the Ancients knew I
wonder if we're going to get to to a
point with technology that we figure out
how to use some sort of diffuse lighting
everywhere where we minimize light
pollution at least minimize it to the
point where you do see stars yeah yeah I
think it really is a bad thing for us I
think it's akin to people not getting
sunlight in the winter they kind of they
don't do well because they don't get
vitamin D yeah I think there's something
psychological like it's there's a
medicine to the all inspiring Cosmos so
funny you said like that I haven't met
Andrew huberman he used to be a
professor at UC San Diego where I am now
he's best love that guy yeah he just
love he's such an an amazing contribute
his whole stick is is get out in the
morning see the morning sunlight what I
want to talk to him about because he's
an expert in the eye and the physiology
of the eye as well as all the other
stuff that he does on his on his uh for
his laboratory right but I want to ask
him about astronomical things like we
see those those that night sky what will
it mean to our physiology and to our
psychology to not to have that robbed
from from a whole we don't we're doing
an experiment nobody knows what will
happen as you just said what will happen
it'll be like will it be like sitting is
the new smoking or sitting is a new
crack or I don't know what it is but but
that's the point what will it mean
there's something deeply into the human
mind the reasons the constellations have
names right is because there was no
Netflix right there was no Netflix 2,000
years ago so people identified things
and they could navigate I can sort of
navigate by I know the constellation is
incredibly which doesn't sound so big a
deal as an astronomer you're like but
most astronomers don't really care they
they don't know the constellations like
one of the jokes is like don't ask me
what constellation is I'm an
astronomer I always give him crap I'm
always like yeah if you were a geography
Professor I'd say like where's Mexico
don't ask me you know it's like kind of
ridiculous but um but not having that
experience and just like you and I
remember what it was like to have have
it at some level or we can go and travel
to it people can't in LA but they can do
something which is which is quite
phenomenal with the same telescope that
you can get an actual version of this
you can connect it to your smartphone
you can have a tripod it's $50 I I made
a video once I said this is the best
Christmas gift you could possibly get a
kid because with it you can see the same
craters on the moon that Galileo saw
light pollution does not obscure the you
know the planets light pollution does
not make impossible I'm not advocating
for light pollution but I'm just saying
right here in the middle of Austin or in
the middle of San Diego I can see the
exact same things that caused Galileo to
realize that they sun is the center of
the solar system